lance thomas fakes whips a pass right to  the hands of middleton  cross court passes  [Applause]  he went to the corner it was picked off  janice  [Music]  [Applause]  i mean the hang time the extension the  lane  that's ridiculous people  [Applause]  and here's that patented spin move that  right to left spin move that he loves to  go to  and then stretch it out extend change it  to the left hand  in there mitch let's see yes  oh my goodness please like an angel  every night that's  nine tenths remaining give us over  inbounds  middleton step back yes yes  yes  before the red light comes on yes he did  i told you it was good wow  watch the long arm of the law poke  poking away to brogden  and making no mistake about this taking  no  [Applause]  chances  [Applause]  [Applause]  finishes off a 27-point evening  with the game-winner what up it's your  boy adam lefkow do you like that content  i know you like that content hit  subscribe  for more of it from bleacher report